في عنا موضوع عن النجم الارجنتيني لاينا
وميسي
يعني ما راح الهلال لكن ميسي اختار شقه في
ميامي الساحره ليستقر فيها مع عائله خلال
لعبه لصالح نادي انتر ميامي الامريكي
اخي البرج بورش ديزاين الذي يتالف من 60
طابقا يحتوي المجمع على مطعم خاص عده
مصاعد لسيارات السكان لنقلهم الى شققهم
ومن اهم ما تتميز به الشقه هو انها متعدده
الاستعلم استعمالات كالسينما صاله العاب
رياضيه وغيرها هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى غرفه
مخصصه عفوا لاستخدام اجهزه محاكاه للجولف
والسباقات بالاضافه الى الساعه
وايضا ملعب للاطفال لكن اجمل شيء موضوع
الاسانسير او مصعد السياره كان رائع
راح راح ميامي ما راح لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات